الان نقف في مقبره الشيخ شعبان الواقعه في
منطقه الساحه هذه المقبره التي جرفتها
قوات الاحتلال وعملت على هرس جثث الاموات
الذين دفنوا في داخل هذه المقبره نشاهد
بشكل اوضح هذه جثه احد الشهداء الذين
دفنوا في داخل هذه المقبره ايضا تسببت
اليات الاحتلال بهرس هذه الجثث هذه ليست
المره الاولى التي تتعمد قوه الاحتلال
تجريف هذه المقابر والعمل على
تدمير القبور واخراج ثث والتنكيل بهذه
الجثث هذه ذخيره قوات الاحتلال في هذا
المكان تتواجد كانت الاليات وهذه اثار
جنازير قوات الاحتلال هذا يعني تدمير لكل
القبور وتنكيل في حق الموتى
هذه هذه ذخائر قوات الاحتلال بعد ان
تمركزت في هذا المكان مزيد من الجثث التي
نكلت بها باليات قوات الاحتلال بقايا
الجثث الموتى يعني احنا ما بدنا نكشف هي
بقا قايا جثه الموتى بالاضافه الى ذخيره
قوات الاحتلال ننتقل الى هي هذه هي شعر
شعر احد احد الموتى هذا شعر احد
الموتى يعني يبدو حتى قوات الاحتلال لم
تراعي حرمه الموتى المتواجدين هذا ايضا هي
هذه جثه هذه جثه جميع هؤلاء الشهداء دفنوا
حديثا طبعا تدمير كامل لهذه المقبره وتعمد
قوات الاحتلال في اخراج جثث الموتى تنكيل
بهؤلاء الموتى هذا ايضا شخص كان مدفونا
و تعمدت قوات الاحتلال على اخراج
[موسيقى]
الجثث هذه ايضا بقايا اكفان وبقايا ما دفن
به الموتى في هذا المكان نشاهد بشكل واضح
في هذا المكان جنازير دبابات الاحتلال
التي داست هذه الجثث
في هذا المكان داست دبابات الاحتلال
الكثير من الجثث في هذا المكان الكثير من
الجثث منتشره في هذا المكان هنا ايضا جثث
اخرى هذه رجل طفل هذه هذا
طفل قصف بفعل قوات الاحتلال والان ينكل به
بفعل قوات الاحتلال هذا ايضا كمان طفل هي
كمان طفل هذا ايضا طفل اخر طفل اخر في نفس
المكان
الذي تواجدت به قوات الاحتلال اخرجت الجثث
من
القبور نحن الان نقف في مقبره الشيخ شعبان
الواقعه في منطقه الساحه هذه المقبره التي
جرفت بفعل قوات الاحتلال بعد ان تمركزت
اليات الاحتلال وداست جثث الموتى التنكيل
حتى بحق الموتى بعد ان ان ارتكبت قوات
الاحتلال المجزره بحق كل هؤلاء المواطنين
الذين دفنوا في داخل هذه المقبره اسماعيل
الغول من مدينه غزه
الجزيره